this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by coors pure upstart liquid iv
and earth fed more on that later let's
get into the do
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all social
media make sure you subscribe to that
youtube channel
and make sure you subscribe to the
patreon if you or someone you know
has that story that has got to be heard
submit it to honeydewpodcast gmail.com
you if you're part of the community you
know if you're not
the wildest [ __ ] i've ever heard in my
life is coming out of you guys and you
have not let me down it's only five
bucks a month i know that's a lot of
money for some people but if you sign up
for a year
you get over a month free episodes all
right um you guys know i record here at
the santa monica music center
we're working with the uh outreach
through the arts with these at-risk
youth kids and the santa monica police
department
doing some podcasts with them so keep an
eye out on that
coming out um and if you're new here hey
we highlight the low lights over here i
always say these are the stories behind
the storytellers
uh we're laughing in the face of
adversity and today's guest
super excited to have on first time here
on the honeydew ladies and gentlemen
please welcome
steve oh y'all welcome to honeydew steve
oh yeah
dude all right all right so listen first
of all thank you for doing this of
course man
um i got to tell you well plug whatever
you'd like first please
i'm amazing man i'm uh all things
stevo uh on social media stevo.com is my
website
and um got a bunch of autographed
[ __ ] for sale at stevo.com right now
posters books even some skateboards but
by the time this is i bet the
skateboards are gone
whatever dude i'm easy well i wanted to
tell you i saw you
what the other night couple weeks ago
yep and that's only the second show i've
done in a year
and i haven't seen you for a minute
which i'll
go back and tell them the first time i
worked with you um and you came right
over to me
and i don't even look like i looked back
then okay and you were like
sickler and i was like and i'm standing
next to josh adam myers
you talk to me you don't talk to him you
walk away and josh goes
man i just saw him like a couple weeks
ago and he didn't even say anything and
i go really
i go man i don't think i've worked with
him
in like six or seven years and i don't
even look like i look here remember he's
like that just happened like
yeah it just happened because it is so
crushing and i just landed
so [ __ ] hard
your honey dude dude i loved it
ah man but the time i worked with you
i i still tell people about ontario
improv
it was the old irvine improv before they
made it the big one
okay and um the first night they made
you stop doing it after this but the
first night you did remember you used to
slice the [ __ ] lemons
yeah and squeeze them in your eyes and i
remember doctors
coming over and saying hey you're gonna
go blind if you're doing that on every
[ __ ] show
that's real acid like you're gonna go
blind
um still to this day the most amazing
[ __ ] bar trick with the rolling over
and not i watched you do it it must have
been a dozen times
and not a [ __ ] drop not even close it
never was close
um you you lit your
this is what you said to me you lit your
hair on fire and after we got to know
each other after a couple shows you're
like
hey will you set my hair on fire and i'm
like [ __ ] no i'm not doing i refuse to
do it i'm like i can't i don't know i'm
gonna [ __ ] it up you had some friend
come up and do it
right and then you chewed the light bulb
and
you know whatever it is well i wouldn't
have been chewing light bulbs at that
point because that's actually really bad
for your teeth
yeah i broke the light bulb on my head
and then
cut yourself and then i used the glass
to cut my tongue
and that's it and put uh like blood all
over yourself yeah and then
stood out in front and took pictures
with people yeah
[Music]
it's a tough game
tough gig for comedy clubs dude
i remember the next night they're like
yeah you can't do that anymore
i mean that was that was the way that i
worked my way into comedy
you know um i thought let me um
promise that it's gonna be all this
crazy stunts and you know lure them in
with the stunts and then win them over
with the stand-up you know that was uh
how i wanted to do it um i i don't know
how well that worked but i just
stuck at it i think the meet and greets
did help a lot because when people
uh the more people you can send home
with the photo from your show
and then they post it on their social
media and let their
people know that they had a good time
that's kind of grass grassroots
promotion that helped me out a lot
and uh as as it sort of evolved my
comedy i stopped doing all the
stunts like in person on stage because
that's just
you can't forever yeah i remember the
guy in his 20s that used to do a flip
on stage and i'm like you better you
better get something out you better get
a new closer bro that [ __ ] ain't gonna
happen in your 30s and 40s right
for sure man um but but then
what i started doing was uh
putting together comedy that was based
on like super
huge stunts and
then as with my show i uh
tell the story of these like
over-the-top stunts and and after the
bit i'll screen the footage
yeah so the footage is exclusive to the
tour and i mean i'm like
[ __ ] butt naked with a guy strapped
on my back blowing a load everywhere as
i fall out of an airplane
yeah that's a closure for my new tour
[Laughter]
it's called skyjacking
there's a lot to it all right so let's
go
let's go back to you who are you talk to
me because i know
i mean i know i got to know you a little
bit over that weekend about clown
college or college right did we really
only work one weekend i think like two
i think it was two we were i think we
worked out and then i would see you and
you really stuck with it and you've
gotten
really good and i'm watching you out
there we were on the show together the
other night
um so where does it all come from tell
me about growing up and
like the [ __ ] you've gone through i mean
dude i was like a rich kid man
you know um not like my dad wasn't born
rich but my dad like became very
successful in business
and um i was born in england
uh 1974 and then
at six months old my family moved to
brazil
because dad got the job of president of
pepsi cola in all of brazil
come on yeah the head of all of pepsi
is the president of pepsi and in brazil
um and uh what the [ __ ] did he come from
to get pepsi
what was his job before that uh before
that he was working for procter and
gamble all right so he's
big companies right there already right
um he was just a hustler man he just
worked really hard i don't even know if
he was
like hey he's a smart guy but like it
was more just like hustle
and um wait i gotta ask you were you
allowed to have coke and [ __ ] around the
house at all
yeah what about
products that was a big [ __ ] deal too
that was like not to be [ __ ] with dude
all right list somebody once told me and
i've been to atlanta
and i don't know if it's true or not but
somebody told me
that in atlanta at the what is it the
taco bell
pizza hut kfc that's all pepsi that
it's coke there and i can't believe that
that's right yeah
i wouldn't buy that so it was a big deal
you guys couldn't have any pepsi or
coke products correct yeah because
coca-cola had clothing for a while when
we were growing up yeah
yes my dad like uh my mom my dad they
were popping off they were
like super successful especially because
if you're making a good living in brazil
then like you're super rich because like
what did your mom do
mom she was a nurse uh
she i think she like just stopped within
the nursing school
you know and and became kind of a
housewife
um but yeah their [ __ ] was popping off
and and they were partying and so
i actually spoke my first words in
portuguese
because i was raised by live-in maids
no [ __ ] yeah that was like my parents uh
what would do you know what it was
what'd they say i couldn't guess
whatsoever
but um but yeah by the age of three i
spoke three languages
no [ __ ] okay yeah like english with my
pain can you still do it
no i forgot i forgot two of them by the
age of five
me with pinocchio a card game
i love it i've learned how to play it
twice but i don't play it enough and it
just i lose that ability
yeah but uh when i was in summer camp
11 years old some kids from portugal
i think they were they said that i was
speaking portuguese in my sleep
which is pretty crazy because like it's
in there but i had
okay do you ever dream in any of the
languages you spoke no
no i wouldn't uh no talking portuguese
in your sleep
mean i did i did when i was 11 and i had
lost
spanish and portuguese by the age of
five all right
so yeah like i was like two years old
moved from from
rio de janeiro in brazil to uh
caracas venezuela because dad got
promoted to like
whatever pepsi in like central america
and
like i don't know it was like uh he got
more of it
and um so i never even lived in america
until i was four
and uh went to kindergarten and
connecticut
um then uh moved when i was six years
old to miami
and uh because your dad's working for
yeah when we moved to miami
dad uh wasn't working for peps anymore
he he was working for rj reynolds
tobacco
he was a [ __ ] big tobacco ceo and uh
we lived in miami for about like three
years
three and a half years and um
then this was during the 80s and but
you're bouncing around obviously yeah
you're not stick you're not meeting
lifelong friends sticking around
communities that sort of thing
you're being raised by nanny so are you
not
close with your mom and dad my mom's
just so [ __ ] busy
mom was a hardcore alcoholic and dad uh
like was like perpetually traveling for
business so like
if there was uh less than the travel
or less than the moving i should say and
switching schools and all that
um i think the the
crazy part for me was
like the inconsistency because dad was
not there
but then when he was there he was like
kind of super strict and like
trying to maybe like compensate for not
having been there
and that just doesn't work you can't
have like
no rules like heavy rules like you know
it can't be on and off like that
and uh you know dad traveled more and
more and and um
mom got drunker and drunker and as i
grew up like the house got bigger and
bigger
because here's what was crazy during the
80s was when they
really concluded that cigarettes were
[ __ ] like cause cancer super achilles
real bad for you
and uh so in sort of a frantic scramble
the tobacco companies
started buying up food companies you
know because they want to kind of switch
their
their eggs from one basket to another
right so it was like at the time
the largest corporate merger that had
ever taken place
uh was when rj
reynolds tobacco bought nabisco
you know they're like investing in food
so that so this merger
it became rjr nabisco and that was dad's
aberrationally good year
[Laughter]
tab is like a real player in that merger
and uh we we went from like doing
well you know dad went from doing well
to being like [ __ ]
like and so that was when i
i was in fourth grade and um we for some
reason
in that whole deal we moved to london
england
and um and once we were in fourth grade
fourth graders halfway
through fourth grade i moved to london
england damn you've lived all over the
place by the time you're in fourth grade
yep and then uh and then
like uh end of sixth grade we moved to
canada
so now i'm in [ __ ] canada and then uh
pepsi's mall of america all over it's
all over that place
yeah we ended up um then halfway through
eighth grade moved back to london
and i stayed in london for all four
years of high school at that point oh
you graduated high school in london
i'd graduated high school from the
american school in london england
and uh this was like a [ __ ]
badass school too like um
they have sports teams it wasn't that it
was like
of my senior graduating class
in high school at the american school in
london
i believe 80 of
the class went on to ivy league schools
damn 80 percent
i believe that i believe that's true it
was some [ __ ]
privileged like you know like the
the american ambassador to england like
was in class with me i
[ __ ] sold the guy weed
you know there's like just like a lot of
you know it was a heavy hitting deal i
was like
a loser for going to the university of
miami which is actually a pretty good
school yeah it's a really good school
and i wasn't ever like
you know i wasn't like a bad kid i
wasn't like uh
even particularly a bad student i was
like b's and c's
you know and then uh beginning of my
junior year 11th grade i i i was like
okay and i'm ready to [ __ ] become a
pothead now like what's up you know
like and i started smoking pot and
taking acid
and and drinking like the junior high
school junior
was high school yeah i was 16 and um
it was just crazy my grades just [ __ ]
plummeted i started getting [ __ ]
arrested and [ __ ] hospitalized all
right wait what's the first
arrest first arrest well in
england it was kind of a kind of there
was like they we got caught smoking weed
one time and like they didn't really
arrest us but
you know we were apprehended we were
like they took the weed and stuff
nothing
then another time uh it's actually the
night before graduation i got
uh thrown and actually locked up in the
drunk tank
what'd you do to get it it was champion
it was like the school we would go to
like [ __ ] pubs
in london you know and uh the drinking
age was 18
whether whether or not you were 18
didn't really matter over there
but it was like you know the pub was
closing like last call everyone finished
up your drinks and i've got this pint
and i'm like i don't know if i said i
was gonna [ __ ] throw the pint glass
at the
[ __ ] wall like at the pub itself or i
was getting ready to go do it like i
pounded it and like someone's like dude
don't [ __ ] throw that glass against
the brick wall
because there's a [ __ ] cop standing
right there and i'm like ah and i
[ __ ] throw it anyway you know and
like smash the glass
ah and then so yeah the cop grab i'll
never forget this too
this is like not a story that i that
i've told a whole lot but uh
i get locked up in this drunk tank and
um
this is the night before graduating high
school
and uh they let me out at like five in
the morning
and like i was still so [ __ ] drunk
that i was like a little bit in and out
of a blackout
still and um i
vividly remember there being like a
staircase
to like i was in somehow in there
upstairs and like
as they released me i walked like i
stopped
halfway down the [ __ ] flight of
stairs to to exit the police station
and just [ __ ] pissed all over this
i [ __ ] sit down
straight and i'm just standing on the
[ __ ] stairwell
[ __ ] pissing all over it and i
remember this [ __ ] british
bobby these british cops all
[ __ ] pissed he's super pissed he
[ __ ] like
he [ __ ] comes up to me i remember him
handing me a mop he says you're [ __ ]
mopping up your bloody bastard or
whatever
[ __ ] and like i'm like oh [ __ ] and i
[ __ ] like
mop up the piss and get them back mom
and i just continue out
you know i was like it wasn't like they
locked me up again
yeah right mop that up okay i mopped it
up and then
and then off i went i went home because
i slept for a couple hours and then
there i was graduating high school
with all these [ __ ] smart privileged
kids
and that was kind of what i was like man
like i was uh
i [ __ ] got started getting [ __ ] up
and and started blowing it man
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor coors pure
do you ever feel like living a healthy
lifestyle is hard like
you try so damn hard to keep up with
what's considered
healthy all right living a healthy
lifestyle is important but it shouldn't
stop
your enjoyment that's when you reach for
coors pure
since it's all organic and has zero
sugar you can enjoy it without
feeling guilty look i'm a lightbeard
drinker always have been and now
that's a smarter light beer it's all
organic tells you right on there 92
calories
no sugar usda organic all right
new coors pure is a refreshingly simple
beer with organic barley organic hops
and water at 92 calories
and zero sugar is the perfect beer to
celebrate the wins of everyday life
coors pure is all about promoting
balance and giving aggressive
affirmations
to everyday heroes coors pure is the
perfect beer
to celebrate the winds of everyday life
so when you want to enjoy a beer without
the guilt
reach for coors pure it's organic but
chill about it
go to coarseburg.com to see where you
can find coors pure i found mine
in target you can find it everywhere you
don't have any excuses
celebrate responsibly coors brewing
company albany georgia
when it comes to paying off debt it can
often feel like an uphill battle high
interest rates resulting in minimum
monthly payments keep you in an endless
cycle of debt
upstart can help you get ahead upstart
is the fast and easy way to pay off your
debt with a personal loan
all online so whether it's paying off
credit cards consulting high interest
debt
or funding personal expenses over half a
million people use upstart
to get a simple fixed monthly payment
unlike other lenders
upstart looks at more than just your
credit score like your income
and your employment history this means
that they can offer smarter rates
with trusted partners and with the
five-minute online rate check you can
see your rate up front for loans between
1000
to 50 000 you can receive funds as fast
as one business day after accepting your
loan look
up starts here because you guys keep
using them and i've gotten so many
messages from you guys saying that
you're so glad you did it you got one
easy payment your interest rate's good
you're knocking it down i wish i had
something like this
i've told you before i i just kept
spending it on credit cards and you know
how it is you're paying that interest
you're not getting anywhere just do it
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
honeydew that's upstart.com
honeydew don't forget to use my url to
let them know i sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit your income and certain
other information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com
honeydew now let's get back to the do
you know like
my grades turned into [ __ ]
d's and f's like by the time i was in my
senior year so
the only the only way i had gotten into
the university of miami was because i
applied on early acceptance
oh they got you i think i did i think i
might have
yeah i planned at the very beginning of
my senior year
and that was like when the wheels fell
off so like
i was already into the university of
miami i was like all right whatever
well how did you do in miami
that was when i really really [ __ ] up
i wasn't even
i mean i mean miami my god i can't even
imagine
within and this is this is so great too
like there's a couple things that i've
never really
like uh brought a lot of attention to
but
the very first day that i showed up on
campus at the university of miami as a
freshman
ah was the the
that night was hurricane andrew hitting
miami
and hurricane andrew was like the most
devastating [ __ ] hurricane like
you know maybe until katrina or
something it was [ __ ] gnarly and they
had it on the
doppler graphs or whatever and they're
like okay i remember them telling us
that first day i shared with my dad uh
and they said this [ __ ] hurricane
tonight
is is gonna be huge so this is your dorm
room here's your your bed did don't even
don't even [ __ ] open up your bags put
them in the closet on the top shelf
and [ __ ] close the door hopefully
they'll be okay you know
like pretty much it's just like and uh
and and like at at a certain time like
whatever's gonna be like eight
eight pm or some weird thing they said
we are going to evacuate all of the dorm
rooms
into the hallways you know because in
the in your dorm room is just not
[ __ ] going to be safe period so we
will all be evacuated into the hallways
at such and such a time where all
we're just going to have like uh we're
all going to be in the hallway
and i was like man that sounds like
[ __ ] dude i don't want to fight
first night
is my very first night like actually
that was what we showed up to
and uh i was like dude that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude i'm not into that
so i went around uh
i went i went around for that that whole
day
like you know meeting that meeting
people hey what's up
and and my first question was hey do you
have the art game in our apartment
you know you have your own place and uh
yeah i met some guys they had an
on-campus apartment
and uh and i said hey man like i know i
don't
[ __ ] know you or anything but dude i
don't want to be in the hallway
can like i said i said if you guys let
me crash in your apartment dude i will
buy
all the [ __ ] beer that you can
possibly and they're like okay cool
so i was not in my dorms
like when the [ __ ] evacuation orders
took hold i'm
i was [ __ ] getting hammered with
strangers with my new bro
and like as the [ __ ] like 10 o'clock
like 11 midnight like whatever and the
[ __ ] shit's starting to [ __ ]
really blow around
like we're [ __ ] drunk off our
asses like just cruising around campus
like [ __ ] with beers in public so
we're like [ __ ] cops start [ __ ]
hiding in hallways we don't care
we do whatever we want and [ __ ]
there's this big lake
uh on campus at the university of miami
and
like i i don't know i'm not gonna say it
was during the hurricane because like
when the hurricane really hit trees were
flying everywhere you know but like
way after you had to be evacuated and
while the [ __ ]
it's more than your average storm
and i'm [ __ ] swimming across the lake
with with one of these guys with one of
these guys
and i i got in the water with my [ __ ]
full clothes [ __ ] jeans and
everything and like
i wasn't like i'm not gonna say i'm a
bad swimmer
but i wasn't like in swimming shape
coming from england you know
like yeah and i'm like gators also
you're not even thinking of that
i wasn't i wasn't tripping about that
but uh but i remember like
this guy like that i was with like kind
of saved me i'm like [ __ ] drunk and
like my jeans i'm not swimming so good
and like
i [ __ ] uh i'd like take off my my
jeans like mid
swim and the guys [ __ ] kind of help
me out [ __ ] but we made it across the
lake
and uh and then i was so [ __ ] drunk
like when when i i passed out in these
dudes apartment
like i i woke up and i was like what was
it a false alarm to the [ __ ]
hurricane
and they're like dude you just [ __ ]
laid there
asleep you never even woke up we were
[ __ ]
freaking out screaming our heads off
like trying to hold on to the walls
because this whole [ __ ] building was
shaking
i never even woke up not once dude
that's crazy
more detail than i ever told that story
dude
yeah i was super stoked man [ __ ] that
was my first day at the university of
miami
so then the next day [ __ ] powers out
for like seriously out like there's not
like we're having [ __ ] warm beer
[ __ ] parties like they're just like
what can we if we can't
start the [ __ ] school like with no
power like the whole [ __ ] grid's
[ __ ] shot like this is like they're
like so they just announced like
all right we're uh we're just gonna not
start
for like another two weeks or something
so just figure out what you're gonna do
and i and i [ __ ] off over to st louis
where my sister was at and just chilled
with her
uh to come back when the school is
actually up and running
and snap classes start within
one week of classes starting
i'm [ __ ] so out of control like with
the
smoke and weed and [ __ ] all the
alcohol and everything
i i come back to my uh to my
dorm room and there's like some [ __ ]
little thing on the door to be like
all right we have raided this room
because the thing was that my roommate
my roommate was like a really he was
like an architecture student he was like
really [ __ ] studious all about like
you know i think he was paying his own
way to be there
you know like this is that he wasn't
[ __ ] around and he couldn't sleep
because i'm [ __ ]
screaming to [ __ ] a party you know
so like nothing against that guy i mean
he did what he had to do
he was like yo [ __ ] get this [ __ ]
got out of here you know
like come in here i'll show you where
all these [ __ ] little weed bags are
and all that
you know those big ass uh like it's in
this pepsi can
and
yeah do they have those things where you
unscrew the can dude
i use those like a [ __ ] but uh
that you know those big old
hampers like um it's like the it's like
a blue
canvas oh they had one of those [ __ ]
things filled with [ __ ]
that much like like beer cans and
[ __ ] bottles like
[ __ ] it was just like they use that [ __ ]
to to take all my [ __ ] alcohol out of
their
animal my weed and everything and so
so that with that ring that's like a
laundry
you talk about like a laundry plastic
yeah like a prison laundry
i wasn't there i wasn't even there when
they raided the room i was just told
that that's what they where they wheeled
out all my [ __ ]
in that i don't know how full it was but
um
but as a result of that raid um i got
kicked out of that dorm
i was placed on final disciplinary
probation
within one week
final disciplinary probation do one more
[ __ ] up and you're out
and so they relocated me because
obviously i couldn't be roommates with
that guy anymore
um they relocated me to this other dorm
this twelve story
[ __ ] was called the towers like uh
the
this twelve story tower and um they put
me on a floor
with like all juniors and seniors you
know like they thought okay
and let this [ __ ] up kid let him be in
the mix with like older students
or maybe like [ __ ] less partying and
create
and these [ __ ] guys on the floor
in the towers man i was like i forget
i was way up in the like uh towards the
top these guys
saw howard's carrying on they said look
dude
we will throw you a [ __ ] party a
party we're not even really purged we
will throw you a [ __ ] party
if you manage to get uh
so much as a 2.0 grade grade point
average which is like c
yes c yeah you you get straight c's
yeah we will throw you a [ __ ] party
they said
they said the way that you are
conducting yourself we do not see a
chance that you're gonna break a 2.0 and
i was like
but the thing was and i learned this
about about college
is that my attendance was decent that's
the ticket dude
if you go to class then you know when
to do the minimum amount of work it's
when you stop going to class
that you don't even know when to [ __ ]
right you don't even know what that you
don't even know you don't even know when
to do the minimum amount of work
so so yeah and like i ended up getting
[ __ ] what did i get i think i might have
gotten like
ah dude i know i have my transcript at
home i forget what it was
it wasn't a two 2.9 but i don't know
like it was two point
something and all you needed was a 2.0
oh yes these guys are these
yeah like maybe it was a 2.2 i don't
[ __ ] have i got better than i know
for damn sure i got better than a 2.0
but here's what here's what happened
right towards the end of that first
semester
i met this chick and she was in the the
on the floor below me it was like guys
floor and then girls every other
you know a boy girl boy girl floor and
it started out like
she was pissed because i was making
noise or something you know
like she was in the room directly
directly below mine she was like
complaining about all the noise i was
making above
and that was like how we [ __ ] linked
up and this was my chick
so then like i got the passable grades
but so wait the one guy complains about
you and gets you kicked out
and the chick complains about you and
hooks
yeah right and uh
this would be the chick that ended up
[ __ ] breaking my heart so bad you
know like
i came back that second semester and i
just lived in her dorm room
you know i lived in her dorm room i was
so stoked on her
i just [ __ ] like i was life is so
good i've got this red
chick i'm [ __ ] in my hair i just like
i just stopped going to class man
i just stopped going to class and i was
just having fun
and uh and then that semester
i ended up i think with like a
a 0.7
i didn't even get a 1.0 dude i was under
i i [ __ ] yeah dude it was bad that
was my second semester it was a
point something not even a 1.0 and and
this chick
like she parted her [ __ ] ass off too
but she took [ __ ] serious you know
and um she was just disgusted with me
and and i [ __ ] my god my now like my
[ __ ] grade point average he averaged
average together my key middle of
gpa is not good and and i come back the
next
oh dude i was my family's still in
england
right and i'm [ __ ] so so we got jobs
me and this chick
my girl at summer camp counselors
okay in new york state she she lived on
staten island
so we're like new york she's [ __ ] and
she and her
her family like her they work so
hard you know they work so hard and
[ __ ] like
tons of jobs like just crazy work ethic
and to to really provide
she's got this nice bedroom with this
water bed we're going to be
[ __ ] so we show up
and uh we showed up
and i showed up to to her place
and the rule with her parents is like
okay you have a boyfriend that's cute
he's not sleeping in your [ __ ]
bedroom
right they're just we're not rocking it
like that you know
like and so we've
this is the [ __ ] worst this is the
[ __ ] worst
we [ __ ] uh
go out and my birthday is june 13th at
the beginning of the summer
you know we're getting ready to do this
and uh we go and she takes me out for my
birthday
and i'm i'm an alcoholic as [ __ ] already
i'm just gonna i'm
already [ __ ] three sheets to the wind
but on top of that everyone's like oh
it's your birthday cool let me get you a
shot you know
like and so i'm like [ __ ]
went went beyond what was so
if we come back to her house i'm so
[ __ ] hammered
like uh we get and i'm not allowed in
her room but
she brings me under her bed she i told
her she's got a [ __ ] water bed
you know she's got a [ __ ] water bed
and
and and i pass out and i wake up and
she's [ __ ] furious
and we are [ __ ] in her water bed like
swimming
in [ __ ] i've just been laying there
just pissing
everybody
[Music]
i've been pissing on her it's like
creating a [ __ ]
uh like a kiddie pool of piss that we're
like [ __ ]
that we're like [ __ ] swimming in and
and she wakes me up and like not even
easily and she's like you [ __ ] she i
remember
saying like [ __ ] deal with this you
know i [ __ ] fix this
so i realized oh [ __ ] i just [ __ ]
pissed all over her in her water bed
which i wasn't supposed to be in to
begin with and so i'm like all right
she told me like the laundry rooms
downstairs but she's got this big old
duvet
on the water bed right and now my job is
my job is to go and [ __ ] put that in
the [ __ ] much of your piss if you
cleaned up
it's not the first time in the middle of
the night yeah
or in jail or anywhere else oh my god i
did it at my great uncle's house
it's
so i bring the duvet down to their
laundry room right and this is like the
laundry room where the washing machine
like loads from the top so you open it
up from the top
and it flips over but it's got like a
mechanism where
the machine knows if the door is open or
not you know and it's on this like thing
right so i open up the [ __ ] to top
the top [ __ ] the hatch or whatever
and it's open
now i heave this [ __ ] piss soaked
[ __ ] duvet
up on top to [ __ ] load it into the
washing machine
but it is so [ __ ]
heavy with all this piss that as i
[ __ ]
heave the [ __ ] thing on it the the
top door of the washing machine which
was open
[ __ ] breaks under the weight it break
it be bro it literally broke under the
weight
of the bishop duvet so now
it's [ __ ] broken and and i can
[ __ ] get the pistol to be in there
[ __ ] but that machine's not gonna run
and so i'm like oh this [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know i don't even know i don't even
know how i think we went to some other
[ __ ] room
or whatever like i don't even know but
it's but the
mom gets up in the morning oh you know
maybe i'll have some coffee oh
looks like the washing machine is broken
it's like walking out to your car and
the door's ripped off
yeah the washing machine is broken
here's a [ __ ]
piss-soaked duvet just that i got to
deal with now
and like oh oh and that's because this
[ __ ] [ __ ] has been
[ __ ] my daughter in the bed that we
told him not to be
it and
and dude and and then like so the the
so the girl whose bed it was my
girlfriend
she says you know what dude i'm not
going to the [ __ ] summer camp i'm
just not i'm not
then you go you go and you [ __ ] be a
summer camp counselor and
you can [ __ ] be rad you know
i'm just not gonna i'm not gonna do it
i'm backing out i'm really not into it
so i go to the summer camp and i think i
lasted three days
i got real hammered i got [ __ ]
like they didn't catch me how old were
the kids you were working with like
middle schoolers
dudes these [ __ ] kids like oh how old
are they there i don't know maybe like
12
years yeah that's the best age when
you're dead and like
these [ __ ] kids loved me dude
they like they loved me so much that
when i got fired
and they fired me just because they
heard i was smoking weed
and the one activity on that whole
summer camp there that
every [ __ ] kid that you want it's
like when they they have the
the free alternative hour where like you
can go
anywhere you want the entire [ __ ]
camp goes to the go-kart tracks
and there's every [ __ ] kids at the
go-kart tracks and they can't even get a
ride because every [ __ ] kid's there
and on the day that i got fired like my
cabin
was assigned to the goat cart so they
had no crowd no [ __ ] bride and
and they loved me so much they were so
[ __ ] bent out of shape
they were losing me maybe that lasted a
whole week i don't know because i had a
relationship with these kids yeah they
[ __ ] went on strike they didn't even
go to the uh
[Music]
so this and then i'm like oh oh [ __ ] i
got fired so
like you know i tell my girl like hey
man like it's
it's like she comes to like pick me up
and i'm like
pretty sure that i'm just gonna like you
know i'll get a job while i'm staying at
her place
but it wasn't in the cards dude she was
like hey man like
you gotta go you know you gotta go so i
went and spent the rest of that summer
with my sister in st louis and i was
like
come back i come back from my second
year at the university of miami
and i'm like that there was no
indication that i didn't have a
girlfriend
you know i probably could have suspected
it but i
showed up to two [ __ ] really like uh
painful things man
oh man when i got to my dorm room
it said they have like a [ __ ]
construction paper on there it says like
it says steve glover freshman and i'm
like
i'm a [ __ ] sophomore man this is my
second year and then i realized
oh i didn't get
[Music]
i i didn't get enough credits like
or like i failed too much like 0.7
or whatever like yeah but that means i
forgot your party
uh well yeah i can't remember if there
was a problem i wanted to say because if
you had a two-point like
just focused on nine yeah and then you
[ __ ] off
and it it kept you under that two points
oh it definitely did me under yeah
but i think that the party was supposed
to happen at the end of the first
semester
and i just don't know that it did i
wasn't like those guys couldn't hang
with me anyway
i'm not sure anyone right
so i find out i'm still a freshman i
don't know why that hurts so bad but i
find out i'm still a freshman my girl
shows up and she's like nah we're not
together anymore like we're
we're broken up and i'm just [ __ ]
like kind of heartbroken man
i had never been heartbroken before and
i was like [ __ ]
dude and that was where like the stunts
initially like i mean i like when i was
blown off class
like that last semester instead of going
to class i was at the pool
the university of miami pool with
[ __ ] like the killer diving board
wait the actual pool the swim team you
[ __ ]
i'm not swimming i'm bouncing on the
diving boards like getting rad
[ __ ] like skateboarding you know
i really got into learning how to do
flips and stuff on the diving boards
and so then when when i'm you know my
girl breaks up with me and i'm like
i'm like all right now i'm going to
[ __ ] instead of going off the
diving boat i learned the i learned the
flips on the diving boards now i'm going
to do them off
buildings you know just i'm gonna
[ __ ] climb on buildings and [ __ ]
do flips into [ __ ]
so creepy shallow pools let me ask you
this this chick thinks i'm gonna die
yeah i'm slapping i wanted her to be
worried about me prior to
to doing this yeah the flips on the
board
at miami you weren't really doing that
kind of [ __ ] prior to that
i'd been making skate videos in high
school but nothing like flipping off a
building or
nothing like that no so now you're
you're taking this to the
legit next level not now i'm trying to
jump off buildings i had like my drunken
buddies and i
like one of the guys had like like rock
climbing ropes
and [ __ ] like it's like yeah i'll
take you we'll go rappelling off the
building that's the only time i ever
went to the [ __ ] library on campus
yeah yeah and my buddies are like we're
all tripping on acid
[ __ ] time we're tripping on acid
trying to tie the ropes to the
banister and [ __ ] like uh there was a
[ __ ] cop car one time we did it
cop car was parked at the bottom and
we're up on the roof pissing onto the
so loud the piss landing on the cop car
if i care like [ __ ] you
so now i'm like repelling off buildings
i'm jumping off buildings
i'm like [ __ ] i learned how to get
[ __ ] choked out real good
you know like i i started building you
jumped off
of at the first time it was a
three-story apartment building and i
only jumped off like the second floor
balcony
that's still two stories yeah no it was
a second floor balcony so one floor up
one floor up
yeah like the and then and then but it's
only a five foot deep pool and i'm six
feet
tall so i've had to figure out like hit
the water and curve in
then then i went up to the third floor
balcony
you know i started jumping off there and
then i figured out climb on the roof
and i'm jumping off the roof and uh all
on campus
uh this this happened uh across the
street from campus okay
and then like dude within that and were
you liking it you like that adrenaline
initially i was really just trying to
[ __ ] concern
you know dude that 12-story tower
right like dude this was the
the 12-story tower and i'm living on the
12th floor when i'm back there
right i don't know if i was on i was on
the 12th floor
maybe the whole time i was on the 12th
floor but it's notable because
the stairwell was detached
from the building itself so you've got
on every floor
there's a balcony you know you open up
the door from the
to like and there's a balcony and then
there's the stairwell right
right well dude i have footage from them
because my
my uh my granddad and while i was with
the chicken
and uh with the water bed was when
my uh granddad died he was like a step
granddad
and my my mom's mom who's married to him
was such a gnarly alcoholic that [ __ ]
she just sat there and drank with the
body
i swear to god so she was like out of
booze and then she dealt with situations
yeah and she flew but he's gonna ain't
going anywhere yeah for sure
yeah straight up my mom's family every
single [ __ ] leaf on the tree is just
straight [ __ ] hardcore gripping with
[ __ ]
saturated saturated
my mom her sister like uh and it was all
from alcohol i mean yeah pretty much
dude
like uh yeah dude it's gnarly it's
[ __ ] gnarly
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our next sponsor liquid iv when we
push our body hard or we're just feeling
run down it's extremely
important to take care of ourselves with
the proper vitamins and nutrients that's
why liquid iv created hydration
multiplier
plus immune support to maintain and
strengthen
your immune system i've told you guys i
used liquid iv all throughout corona
when i had it i'm still using it even
after these vaccinations i was wiped out
tired i've been using the immune boost
using the energy
um and i love it i've given them the
josh adam meyers using them now ash is
using them my booker emily everybody's
using them here
and they love them they keep wanting
more so um
i highly recommend liquid iv especially
if you're into that sports drinks you're
out there being active or stuff it's so
easy to carry with you take with you
liquid iv can provide two to three times
more hydration than water alone it's the
perfect balance to help you strengthen
your immune system
more quickly and effectively when you
purchase liquid iv
you're joining their mission to help
people live better lives everywhere with
every purchase liquid iv
donates a serving of liquid iv to
someone in need the company has donated
over 10 million servings globally
all right get your liquid ivs hydration
multiplier plus immune support
in bulk at costco or order online and
get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com and use
code honeydew at checkout
that's 25 off of anything you order when
you get
better hydration today using promo code
honeydew
at liquidive.com our next sponsor is
earth fed
why earth fed well there's a lot of
reasons why but one of them is it's good
for your gut
so it turns out if you don't put trash
in your stomach you don't end up feeling
like trash in other words
poison is poisonous so they avoid it in
their formulations right now
as a member of night pants nation you
get 10 off the best tasting cleanest
supplements out there and
you can also take your pick of free
12-week training programs written by a
usa weightlifting international
team coach choose the body weight
training for 12 weeks of workouts you
can do at home at the park
or in your parents basement if that's
where you're at no judgment
just get that work done playa if you're
looking for mobility and strength choose
the free 12 weeks of yoga fit
which uses some equipment and some body
weight training to keep you agile and
supple like a cat
a combined three decades of coaching
food processing and nutrition experience
goes into every supplement they make
and they're so clean they've got pro
ballers and olympians on the squad efm
keeps it real because their parents
their kids make their chocolate milk
with their whey protein and i'll tell
you what every day
i've been using the collagen ash took
the protein powder
i'm using the collagen i throw it in my
breakfast shake every morning i love it
it's great stuff
i even just throw it in water at the end
of the night or tea it dissolves
you don't even know it's there it's
super beneficial for joints everything
else going on
head over to earthfedmuscle.com honeydew
and use discount code honeydew10
to get your free body weight or yoga fit
12 week training program and you'll save
10
on your first order of grass-fed whey or
collagen today
that's earthfedmuscle.com honeydew and
use discount code
honeydew10 now let's get back to the do
and uh but uh it was it was that when i
was there like during [ __ ] round and
so we went to like clean out
like whatever it was for my dead
step-grandad
and he had a video camera and i got it
so now i got that [ __ ] video camera
from my dead step granddad
and like i'm vietnam videotape so i'm
one of the first things i filmed and
this was [ __ ] up
i'm on the balcony of the
that 12th floor balcony and it's got the
railing
with the f you know and i [ __ ] to
figure out like okay i'm going to
climb over the railing on the 12th floor
no
man i get an anxiety just listening
and i'm gonna and i'm gonna and i'm
gonna climb down just
and drop onto the 11th floor below you
know and
it was like just creepy but dude that i
can't keep doing it
so so you went down all the way now i
just went from 12
11 i'd do that it was gonna be bill
right from 12 to 11.
but then but then i started doing it
where i climb over and my hands are on
the rails like toward
the top of the railing right and i just
[ __ ] kick my feet off and just sort
of loosen my grip on my hands a little
bit so my hands
slide down the rails
to this day that's one of my favorite
[ __ ] clips dude
i just put it in this i just put it in a
video on my
youtube channel i posted it today on my
ig
a video of why they call me stevo and i
was like i was doing [ __ ] up [ __ ] and
right when i say really dangerous [ __ ]
like it's me sliding down the 11th floor
but then because the stairwell is uh
separated from the building and
there there's like for the roof access
there's uh
like a 13th stairwell
right it's 13th in in the stairwell so i
go up to the
top of the 13th and there's like the
door to the
to the roof is locked but there's a
window at the top
and so i [ __ ] smash out that window
on camera i smash
out that window on camera and i climb
out the window and [ __ ] like i don't
even remember it being like
a gnarly jump or anybody climb out the
window and like over the balcony gap
onto the roof from out that window [ __ ]
now i'm on the roof of the 12 story
building and come around to the
the roof access door on the other from
the roof side
it doesn't lock so i go out there i'm on
the roof and i open it up
and i'm like yeah come on in everybody
so now we're on the roof
and like and i was i'd be like oh yeah
you guys want a [ __ ] party on the
roof
i just go up and climb out the window i
broke open up the door yeah cause you're
the only one that's gonna do that [ __ ]
right
but i got the key yeah there's no party
on the roof without stuff
but but here's the and dude like that
was already where i'm bringing chicks up
there like we're just drinking
on the roof like it's like fun you know
but here's where
it went too far on the roof of the 12
straight building there was like
another level there like uh there's
another level and from that other level
came like this huge tall radio tower
with guy lines and stuff so while we're
up on the roof one night drunk as [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] i climb up onto that second
level and i start
climbing up the radio tower all the way
up to the [ __ ] top insane
straight to the very top of the radio
tower on top of the [ __ ] 12 story
building
and even though it's got all the guy
lines like this [ __ ] thing
swaying [ __ ] one way or the other you
know
and it's like it's like night it's dark
and [ __ ] but someone on the ground is
like
that's someone climbing up the [ __ ]
radio tower on top of the [ __ ] towers
like that's not okay
so they [ __ ] call the cops and i'm up
there like [ __ ]
entertaining my [ __ ]
and [ __ ] cops just come out onto the
[ __ ]
roof like from the from the uh the roof
access doors
your door yeah your key yeah i mean i
think
but i think someone opened it up for him
but yeah a bunch of cops come onto the
roof and
then they're like all right and so then
and i was on final probation
so that was it sorry i was out no i got
kicked out of the dorms for that
and you're saying i've said i've said
for a million times
like i've told them the story a million
times just that
i was on final probation got kicked out
of the dorms and my grades were so bad i
just gave up by up and left
so i [ __ ] up at the university of
miami every way you possibly can
pretty much um but i've never like
really told the story about climbing up
the radio tower as much
dude you've given me the gold on honey i
appreciate it and uh so now
now i gotta wait i gotta ask you've
never a fear of heights or any other
[ __ ]
never oh dude i'm terrified of roller
coasters then why how can you get up on
something that's moving like that well
just
i don't know dude like uh i'm an
attention [ __ ] that's my only
explanation so if a girl if you wanted
to get a girl's attention you would go
on a roller coaster
i mean i don't like it i i i i you know
like on on the wild boys show they they
they built me [ __ ] like condorman
wings
to make bungee jumping funny they're
like just flap the wings
you can fly and i'm like i can't jump
off the bridge you know
like there's no [ __ ] way i was gonna
say is there anything you'd said no to
i couldn't do it i was like dude i just
can't do it i was like maybe because
i've been jumping off [ __ ]
starting with like the little balcony
and then the next balcony and then
working my way up
like i've i've i've assessed like
everything and like looking around like
what can i jump off this
and i'm just too close to the problem
like i don't care what you tied to me
like i can't look off a 200 foot bridge
and and jump like it's just i can't get
past that in my head
and and the same thing with like roller
coaster i don't [ __ ] like it man
they're designed yeah right that's
science right now it's
yeah i don't like it but uh but just
there's something about
all the [ __ ] that i did where i just
kind of figured it out and worked my way
up
and like it sort of expanded my comfort
zone or something you know so i kind of
like understand
these things but yeah i got kicked out
of the dorms
now i'm [ __ ] straight homeless now
does that mean out of the university or
just
off the property i i that i still was
10. i was
i couldn't i could still attend classes
i could still attend classes but i
wasn't allowed in the dorms
um and uh
and dude i wasn't even [ __ ] trying
dude
i think this kid that was like i'm over
it dude and he was [ __ ] bailing out
and
he had a van he's gonna drive from miami
to to
northern california to like be rad
snowboarder
so yeah if you get a job on the mountain
you get a free lift pass and you live in
the
employee apartments and i was like right
on dude i'm [ __ ] rad let's go
and so we [ __ ] went it didn't really
work out
and i ended up going to texas and having
the government
test drugs on me for cash what do you
what kind of drugs
drugs for pigs and cows the more the
more the more tell me about i swear to
the more dangerous
the more dangerous the medical study the
more they pay you
so you're gonna take you're gonna test
out toothpaste you're making like 20
bucks
right i got two grand pal
i got two grand and and uh
how long are you there like what was
that
was it 12 days it was supposed to be
well dave
it was supposed to be less i think it
was supposed to be 10 days
but but the the like the the
the goal of the study was to give us
this drug
until somebody's resting heart rate like
went over 150 beats a minute or so
you know something [ __ ] up and uh and
what the drive was
the drug was called rack dopamine
hydrochloride
and they were giving it to they they
wanted to make it legal to give to pigs
and cows
so that it worked like somehow like
steroids but like in a
like another way but to make the
the cattle have less fat and more muscle
okay so that they could like extensively
like kind of
you know create leaner meat to appeal to
a more health-conscious consumer
but the the fda hang-up was that if you
do that with that cattle
then when people eat that meat then this
this drug
is going to enter the human body and by
that logic now we have to test the drug
to see like how much the human body can
[Laughter]
take
yeah like uh so i was doing that and uh
there was this crazy episode with one of
the guys in the study which is
gonna say there's only six people
allowed in the study because they didn't
want to do it to too many people
but one of the other six people was uh
this like drug dealer dude from colleen
texas and we're like oh we want to
invest our money we're going to buy a
pound of weed
and then if i can make make it last
and so this guy [ __ ] was like i could
hook you up we're staying this
guy's place and he takes us to do the
deal but he goes out the back door with
all our money
oh [ __ ] and we [ __ ] found our way
back to his place because we drove
you know i mean this this guy had met on
yeah
we drove and we found our way back that
wasn't and you know
this guy [ __ ] it was just a bad scene
dude
it was it was a bad scene i ended up
coming back to the university of miami
and just being straight homeless and
like this was
now uh the beginning of 1994
and i was still living on campus
homeless
while the people where did you go just
oh dude
um i would stay like on people's floors
and stuff
there was one apartment that in the
the student apartments but this was like
the athletic
apartments see like i'm at this point
i'm starting to get like
like more aggressive on my stunts i'm
like i've got now i'm [ __ ] i'm gonna
be a [ __ ] rad stuntman
and uh at the olympic pool at the
university of miami
this and it's it's an olympic factory
you've got the [ __ ]
the wall has like greg louganis the most
famous
diver of all time the diving towers are
there
and uh at that time
was it was uh the the 95-96
school year they had the number one
number two and number three ranked
ncaa platform divers damn
living in the same apartment
with like there's four of them in
there's there's number one two and three
ten meter platform divers and a random
swimmer
like uh living in this apartment and
these guys were the [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know like they were like rock stars
at the school you know my one buddy in
particular brian cooley who was number
one he had just
qualified first place and made first
place at
nationals the the national junior
national
he won 10 consecutive junior national
titles yeah
from like yeah they were like these guys
were badass
and and they were partying like rock
stars and they [ __ ] party with
luganus
no not all games the games have been
there before yeah these guys ended up
with their murals all three of these
guys got their murals
like next to the danis but uh but yeah
dudes
and these guys were [ __ ] partying
we're all and i'm like this
crazy [ __ ] stevo character who like
nobody really wanted
me like sleeping in their place as much
like but i was fun to have at parties
and kind of thing and these guys [ __ ]
fell in love with me man they [ __ ]
let me sleep on their floor
the swimmers the divers the diver
the most [ __ ] elite divers in the
[ __ ]
had they they had me sleeping on their
floor like a lot of the time
and and on top of that they like took me
under their wing and like [ __ ]
trained me
you know like how to do like real
like tight solid clean back flips is
that right
and and and uh they had me [ __ ] i was
already like
walking my hands maniac these guys had
me like pressing up
slowly like and perfectly still to a
handstand like holding it still
[ __ ] walking up and down stairs on my
hands
like perfect backflips and and i turn
that [ __ ] around
and uh start lighting myself on fire
and now i wanna jump and doing wait what
first time you ever let yourself on fire
okay
i we had one of our buddies at the
university of miami and he would just
like as a gag
he would [ __ ] um like blow fireballs
like by the pool you're using a lighter
and i've said i've witnessed you
[ __ ] light your [ __ ] head on fire
refused to help
this guy he would click a lighter and he
would spit isopropyl rubbing alcohol
onto the lighter
and make a big fireball well in like
1996
right after i got out of this [ __ ]
10-day jail sentence
you know i [ __ ] go and sign up for
this uh
radio station event where they're
putting on a talent show
and i told them i'm stevo the alcoholic
gymnast
you know i'm gonna [ __ ] get
absolutely [ __ ] whammied before the
audience's eyes
like shotgunning beer after beer after
beer i've got different ways of
shotguning beers but
i might have you know i i wanted to do a
whole 12 pack i ended up doing like
i don't know like nine beers you know
budweiser's
and um i was doing like
shitty acrobatics and [ __ ]
i go and and i'm gonna do a fireball at
one point
well here's what happened dude i [ __ ]
clicked
lighter and
i blew out the flame so i had this like
disappointing [ __ ]
oh it's disappointing didn't lie and it
was like out that dude i had these
people in the audience
like steve oh and while i was in my 10
year
10-day jail sentence i'd just been like
thinking man
i'm really getting rad now you know i'm
getting really [ __ ] rad now i got
like a company giving me clothes
[ __ ] you know i'm getting somewhere
dude i got a career
i'm like but do i want to be stevo like
that's the [ __ ] question do i want to
be stevo and i got my hands on some
[ __ ] papers and i
wrote my jailhouse memoirs in march of
1996.
march of 1996 and i wrote uh the first
thing i
said they call me stevo but i'm thinking
about switching back to steve
glover because now i've begun kind of a
career
and i don't know if i want a nickname
when i'm famous
but then i'm doing the radio station
thing chugging all the beers in the
crowd
screaming steve oh i'm like there's no
[ __ ] way anybody will ever scream
steve glover and so
that was when i decided i'm going by
stevo that's my deal
but i hadn't i had [ __ ] i did i had
them on my side they were stoked it was
just [ __ ] rad
they're screaming my name and then i
blow the [ __ ]
the lighter out with the rubbing alcohol
and it was just [ __ ]
it killed me but but i [ __ ] regret it
i did this show two nights in a row as
well
so maybe it was the next night but i
wanted to be like kind of more careful
whatever at some point i think on the
second night
i go and i [ __ ] click the lighter and
now what i did
was i lit it but
i spit the alcohol all over my hand so
so the the fireball ignited and i'm like
yes sweet not even i'm oblivious i don't
even realize
but as the fireball lit and then now
it's over i feel
oh [ __ ] my hands on fire you know yeah i
turned my hand i'm like
i'm like oh [ __ ] so i'm like you know i
shake my hand out
and it comes it comes out and i'm like
whoa you know like what was notable
about it was that
my hand didn't really get burned you
know
like maybe a little but like it was
sitting there on fire real good
and the rubbing alcohol is like thin
kind of like burns light sort of a deal
and then i
i thought about it and put it all
together i was like dude
i never want to be in a situation where
i [ __ ] fail
on blonde ever again
so i said what if i start out
by pouring just deliberately pouring
rapping out
what if i just pour the rubbing alcohol
on my hand and then
light my hands and i use that as my
torch
as i'm not blowing that out and then i'm
never gonna now i've got a torch and
it's my [ __ ] bare hand
which is awesome and reliable and so i
started doing it like that
like off my hand and now i've got my
back flips all [ __ ] super tight
so that i'm thinking like i've never
blew back in your face or anything
when other people were blowing it off my
head see that's why i didn't want to do
it but i if i remember correctly man
you put a it was a conditioner you
combed a bunch of conditions yeah well
then then what that means is that i was
doing it every night you were working
you did every night every [ __ ] night
it was like pantene
conditioner i feel like i would i would
get because i was trying to like not
i was trying to not let my hair burn all
the way because i needed to keep some
hair around
yeah just like you keep lighting it
right right
you got chicken fenders to sell out
there
and uh and so dude i forgot my back
flips tight and i'm like all right
now i can do killer bag flips what if i
light my hand on fire
i got my mouth full and then as i swing
my arms into my back flip i jump
and [ __ ] as i tuck i blow a fire oh
my god
so i i [ __ ] i straight up invented
the simultaneous fire breathing backflip
and i [ __ ] got that and i was pretty
[ __ ] reliable dude like
i i pulled it you know i pulled it in a
big way and um
that was before i started lighting my
head on fire but uh
i ended up moving out to albuquerque my
sister's living in albuquerque now or
whatever
that's one of the that's when i got
serious serious about [ __ ] now i'm
[ __ ] in albuquerque
there's a radio station there they said
they got a freak of nature contests
and so i call them up and i say all
right i'm going to join your freak of
nature contest i said i'm going to
doubt i'm going to get stripped down to
my underwear and i'm going to douse my
entire body
with rubbing alcohol and have my buddies
with torches
[ __ ] ignite my entire [ __ ] body
and then i'm going to do it perfect
i'm going to do a perfect standing back
flip i'm gonna [ __ ]
ah and then my buddies are gonna put me
out with the with a blanket
and and dude albuquerque is a different
place they were like
they were like bringing that [ __ ] on
yeah i do
i find that it's so crazy that these
stories and
these stories i'm telling you are like
uh
they're i mean literally before when i
was on the way over here
i [ __ ] check this [ __ ] out dude
what's your name there i am with the
[ __ ] that's the cold open
holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
your whole body
albuquerque radio station yeah you can
find it on uh
that was in albuquerque yeah you can
find that on on youtube
in a video i said i called it um why
they call me stevo
and you can find on my instagram it was
about a couple weeks ago i posted it
all right so i get you know wanting the
attention from the girls and everything
how much of this is also
wanting that from your parents or i i
wouldn't doubt
that you know you don't have to be
sigmund freud to figure out that like
you know
mom was drunk and dad was absent you
know did it work though i mean did you
i mean i don't know like uh and i don't
even know how much i want to assign to
to like you know the the family dynamic
i i could have very well just been a
[ __ ]
alcoholic attention [ __ ] no matter what
you know
with talent though yeah who knows i
don't know that i ever had that much
talent but i had
like my dad's side of the family my dad
like i said he was a hustler dude
my dad came from a long line of
academics
his dad was a zoologist a [ __ ] like
decorated like war [ __ ]
hero type dude they had nobody on my
dad's side of the family has less than a
phd
you know like university professors
the theologians clergymen
[ __ ] zoologists like honor
[ __ ] low low earning and my dad was a
little bit of a black sheep for being
the first
person in the family to go into business
like what are you some kind of greedy
capitalist like we're like [ __ ] good
people
well if he's a black sheep what the [ __ ]
are you right
yeah what do you consider and while my
well my dad's dad was like serving
honorably like winning [ __ ]
like a valor awards or whatever like as
a colonel
in uh world war ii my mom's dad
was dodging the draft
and like and and uh and and
becoming like really rather wealthy
um selling boot like gasoline because
for like during war time
they had rations you know like even if
you can afford it we don't care we're at
war
and so you can only buy so much gasoline
and so
my so my uh mom's dad was like a dodge
drafter bootlegger
alcoholic gambler and and he became like
[ __ ]
a millionaire i think doing that but
then he gambled away all of his money
and blew his brains out when i was one
year old
oh [ __ ] see i come from [ __ ] you got
both sides of them
i do so i've got i've got my dad's like
hustle
and my mom's like [ __ ] deviants and
[ __ ]
and my mom like to be fair she was the
one with the
the sense of humor the [ __ ]
intelligence that but you know
alcoholics can be some [ __ ]
intelligent
like charismatic people yeah alcohol
doesn't care if you're dumb or smart or
kind or yeah just but yeah so
it's pretty rare how how like everything
worked out for me that like
it's just so evident that i'm this
fusion of these two
like these two bloodlines you know yeah
man
yeah and i got like i'm the only one i
think from my mom's whole family that
ever got sober
you know at least like for a long time i
just turned 13.
so the only one on your dad's side
without a doctorate and the only one on
your mom's
all right well thank you for coming on
before before we let you go i want to
ask you
i mentioned at the top before we
recorded advice you would give to your
16 year old self now that we've talked
about
what you've talked about coming up i
mean it's interesting like
how i i'm so active
with uh with like my digital
presence you know like my youtube my
[ __ ]
and i make all these videos like uh
for a good couple years now i've been
cranking out these like super
polished like uh sort of story videos
that that really like where i mine
through
like the footage i've been filming since
i was 15 years old you know like it goes
back that long
wow now i'm 40 i said camera where you
put the vhs
in that [ __ ] right like uh i
mean it wasn't my first video camera
that i got from the dead
step granddad yeah that the first video
camera i got
was the one that my dad won in a
corporate golf tournament
and i stole it from his closet and and
uh
before you knew it was gone like i
already like edited a skate video and
showed it to my dad my dad was like
[ __ ] badass yeah
take it yeah yeah you go um but uh so
i've got footage going back for
like 31 years and i
and i like go through so much of it is
just [ __ ] up
drugs and you know like i'm out of
control and so i get
some criticism for uh and not even
criticism but a lot of it's just like
you know objective observation that
like hey man like uh you know
as a sober guy here you are like really
exploiting
like all of this dark like you know like
in a way
celebrating all of this [ __ ]
you know really unhealthy toxic
alcoholism and drug addiction like
in this footage and putting it out there
like check out how entertaining it is
you know and like some people would
think that that's not rad
and so other people say hey you know
like it's like you're celebrating the
survival
right now meet me too and don't think
for one second that
that i have an issue with it
i i i don't and there was somebody who
loved to comment somebody said like hey
man you know like
i know that you're really proud of being
sober and i wouldn't say proud as much
as just grateful
you know i'm grateful for being sober
but um
but you know like it's really pretty
evident that like drugs worked for you
like obviously you know your experience
got you where you were at
this is what i like to hear yes
to that to the kid who left that comment
i said you know
like uh and he said uh
i said yeah i don't i said drugs
worked whenever when i was working
when it was working for me drugs were
good drugs and alcohol were great
you know like and then it just got to a
point where
they turned on me you know and it wasn't
working anymore
and and then thank god like if they
turned on me so bad
it got so [ __ ] awful that i had to do
something about it
and now as a result of that i'm sure i'm
in this great place
or the worst thing that could happen i
think
i think the worst thing is if you have
like alcoholism
kinda yeah where you've got it
enough for it to [ __ ] up your life and
and
prevent you from achieving your goals
and [ __ ] up your relationships
but it's not so bad that it has to be
addressed
so it just goes on and on for years and
the years turn into decades and then
you're
[ __ ] old and you're like [ __ ] what
did i do i blew it yeah you know like
in my that's why i say all the time i'm
grateful that i've got alcoholism
so [ __ ] bad that i don't have to
wonder if i got to do all these things
that server will do
yeah and because i do all the things
that sober people do and i stick with
that crowd
like i'm able to to really be focused
and
accomplish it so there's a long way of
saying that i'd be really [ __ ]
careful if i had an opportunity
to send a message to a 16 year old me
i'd be really [ __ ] careful with the
space time continuum
because i can't tell the kid not to [ __ ]
up because it's gonna work really you
could tell them to wear like a [ __ ]
rubber underwear here's what i would say
is be really [ __ ] diligent about
flossing your teeth and taking care of
your the health of your
your gums and your teeth because
like um
i have a genetic predisposition to not
the best
[ __ ] uh teeth and gums health
and on top of that and this is like this
isn't just advice to my 16 year old me
this is advice to the entire [ __ ]
world
is that some people can get away with
not flossing
and some people cannot get away with it
and i
fell into the latter category i could
not get away with it and what that means
is
that as a result of not flossing and not
taking care of my [ __ ]
i i got bacteria in my mouth now we all
we've all
had this experience where you're talking
to somebody and there's just a [ __ ]
odor coming out of their mouth
and this is not bad breath in the like
conventional like you know way that
we're used to where it's coming from
inside no this is just
like [ __ ] dead [ __ ] back to like
something
something just died behind your tooth
and all the the perfectly good breath
coming from
is just pushing this bacteria out and
like no amount of brushing
can do that i remember when my mom was
alive and i was like allowed in her
house
she would like she would say like dude
your [ __ ] breath is disgusting i'd be
like mom i
just brushed my teeth like five minutes
ago she goes
yeah your breath is [ __ ] disgusting
like like when you have this bacteria no
amount of brushing
is gonna make make it go away you know
like
and i had that for a long time dude i
had that for a long time and i just
didn't understand it
you know i didn't and i would brush more
and it wouldn't do anything right
one time i was getting in the van with
all the jackass guys and and we man goes
ah dude stevo your breath
and knoxville says saying stevo has bad
breath
is like saying we man is short
it's just hot you know and like
we live in uh we live in this this
this culture where for some reason
it's not okay to tell somebody that
their [ __ ] breath
is i i encounter these people you know
like and i want to tell them like hey
look you gotta
this thing i i can smell this thing and
i don't want to
make you feel bad but i'm telling you
that like you've got a
you know like a bacteria you can't smell
it on yourself but you've got like a
bacteria in your mouth
and like and and what i needed to do to
understand this
is like get get some dental floss and
just run it and
run it like uh through your teeth and
then smell the floss
and and if you have the bacteria it's
gonna be on that [ __ ] floss you're
gonna smell it and you'll be like oh my
god
i used to be so insecure when i had
braces because
on not just the rubber bands here but
they would put them around it and when
they would pull that thing off to change
them and tighten it and it would just
lift it in front of my nose oh my god it
would [ __ ]
i'd be like that's a month of food on
that [ __ ] thing
yeah it's gnarly so like and i just
didn't figure it out it was after i got
sober
that i figured i went to a dentist and
the dentist just had that talk with me
was like hey you know you got this
[ __ ] bacteria it's like
you know we gotta do a deep cleaning to
get it out and then you just gotta not
[ __ ] around
and uh and i had gum recession really
bad i'd [ __ ] had
like not countless but like
numerous uh like gum graft surgeries and
that [ __ ] sucked i had bone graft
surgeries from bone loss
i had the years of my [ __ ] just take
care of your teeth and go i'm scared
that's all i want to tell that 16 year
old kid now other than that [ __ ] let
it ride
let it ride plug everything whatever
where it's at and you know like uh my
book dude that's what i saw at stevo.com
is um my book it's called professional
idiot
and uh i just had to say i think it's
the best
[ __ ] thing i've ever you know it like
as a book it's got
um five-star average rating on amazon
which is like pretty unfucking hurt
yeah it is and um it's just
it's like internet's hilarious it's
[ __ ] crazy
it's like inspiring it's just like you
know
like it my story is [ __ ] intense and
i made it that way on purpose and uh
here i've got this
really [ __ ] juicy ass book and the
copies
that i sell from my website stevo.com uh
every
book every copy's autographed nice and
dude
i was signing these [ __ ] autographs
for years
before i realized that even the way i
was doing it steve oh
that the oh like looks like the head of
a dick and that like
it's just like i'm drawing a dick when i
do my [ __ ] signature
and so now like i call it a dickograph
and i do it like really deliberately
i make my so yeah it's like it says
stevo clearly
but it's also like got a [ __ ]
[ __ ] with the shooting
tonight i love it all right well thank
you for coming on man
this was a great time as always ryan
sickler.com on all social media
ryan sickler talk to you all next week
[Music]
you